let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and
do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
well good wednesday afternoon everybody
it's always a news day on wednesday
always and today
[Music]
we're making a ton of news or non-news
about what's going on in helsinki with
biden vs
putin in this corner
ding ding ding everyone's
crazy today about uh biden versus putin
in helsinki and how that meeting went
and what the press conferences were
afterwards and there's a hundred
different views of
what the situation is but
the one thing i took from it was that
this is uh totally predictable
completely totally predictable of what
was gonna happen
that's the good part about having a
president who knows things about foreign
policy
is this stuff is predictable like
you're not gonna just you know go [ __ ]
in the yard somewhere
you got a specific spot you gotta go
take a dump and then you
take a [ __ ] clean it up the dog shits
there
doesn't [ __ ] all over the yard in other
people's yard and in the street
and everywhere on your floor no
now so biden and putin meet today
i think it was about an hour and a half
is what they said and then they they had
a group
meeting a group meeting with both of
their teams
and uh you know
uh i think that joe biden
made uh daddy vlady as i like to call
him daddy vlady
putin switched to the trump brand
diapers
it's obvious that vladimir putin
does not think it was a good idea for
joe biden to be president
which the reason why he thinks that is
because that's probably bad for his
interest
which is good for our interest and
that's the only thing that [ __ ]
matters here
that's it that's it that putin's pissed
that trump isn't president
that's it that's all you need to know
move the [ __ ] on but we're going to talk
about it
we're going to talk about a few things
that vladi daddy
putin said uh makes the republicans look
more like putin's puppies
and you all remember my little video
about putin's puppies we're gonna play
that [ __ ] today
because you know why not bring out the
good videos about these
ninka poot gop [ __ ]
bowing at the feet of vladimir putin
i mean i see pictures of these morons
wearing shirts say i'd rather be a
russian than a democrat yeah no
[ __ ] sherlock we know we know
who you want to be the american
president and that's vladimir putin
i think he's some kind of [ __ ] tough
guy and then we're also going to talk
about
marjorie taylor greene
the space laser lunatic
miss space laser jewish space laser that
is she didn't know what the holocaust
was apparently
so she went and visited a museum to
refresh her [ __ ] memory
so we're going to talk about that which
is going to lead us into steve bannon's
war room and then this nonsense about
about tucker carlson and the fbi and not
knowing what the [ __ ]
how conspiracy charges work in a federal
court so we're going to talk about that
a little bit
and then i'm going to try to dive into
just a bit i was gonna do a lot today
but uh this biden putin thing happened i
was gonna dive into the trump
investigations and how many there are
and there's a
i mean there's just [ __ ] sacks full
of these [ __ ]
i mean they're just [ __ ] everywhere
they're everywhere they're like pecker
nets
on a hot summer day just buzzing around
your head
criminal investigations civil
investigation state investigations
federal
investigations congressional
investigations they're [ __ ]
everywhere
[ __ ] everywhere and these people are
losing their goddamn minds we had news
last night about weisselberg
that he's why so [ __ ] and we will go
into that a bit
i'm sure of it
and then i want to talk about the uh
john stewart clip that everyone uh
seemed to be confused about and i'm
gonna do it very delicately and very
careful here on
on the podcast because we stream live on
youtube
and you start talking about stuff with
the coronavirus and
they start pulling down your [ __ ]
videos
from youtube so we're gonna we're gonna
be a little careful
with how we word things about the jon
stewart clip
so is to not take down this [ __ ] clip
of me talking about that [ __ ] clip
now of course if they take it down we'll
still be published other places twitch
apple podcast spotify and i want to
remind everybody out there
and you're probably watching on these
streaming softwares we stream on uh live
on youtube every wednesday at three
o'clock
central four o'clock eastern on youtube
we also stream live on twitch whatever
the [ __ ] that is
and we also stream live on twitter hi
all my tweeples
i'd like to stream other places but
we're gonna stick to those three for
right now
and then once i'm done here talking and
you
heard me yelling screaming this
microphone i run over to
spotify and apple podcast and take a big
old podcast dump there
and i'll upload the podcast so you can
go listen to it over there
and spread the madness around i guess
get your daily dose of of
dumb [ __ ] from these idiots because
we're going to talk a lot
a lot about dumb buckery today when we
get to the margie taylor green tucker
carlson [ __ ] bunch of dumb [ __ ]
so let's start let's start with the uh
jon stewart clip oh i'd like to start
there that won't take me very long i
don't think
a lot of people were pissed off a lot of
people were cheering
and a lot of people that were pissed off
didn't know why they were pissed off and
a lot of people that were cheering
didn't know why the [ __ ] they were happy
about what he said because they didn't
listen
to what the [ __ ] he said and they don't
understand
comedy they don't understand funny they
don't [ __ ] get it
that's why we keep hearing this word
cancel culture and canceling and all
this [ __ ]
and oh mr joe rogan i'm white and i'm a
male
and oh they're just gonna have to cancel
me
even though i got the loudest microphone
in podcast history
give me a [ __ ] break
and the right wing is so excited so
excited that
that jon stewart told the truth to
liberals
and yet they're pissed off because jon
stewart gets to say what he said on the
late show
without getting cancelled or some [ __ ]
again these people don't know what
comedy is they're not sure what cancer
culture is they don't not sure who to
cancel who to like
they don't know what they believe
anymore is the real [ __ ] problem
and we're going to talk more about that
when we talk more about january 6 later
on
but when we're talking about the the the
coronavirus and the wuhan lab stuff
they don't even know what the [ __ ] they
believe there they have no [ __ ] clue
and they didn't listen to what jon
stewart said in the clip that was
running around the internet in the first
place
in the very beginning you listen to him
set up the joke
he's setting it up he's setting up the
[ __ ] joke folks
and he's being serious he's saying
something that he actually believes
which is that science sadist from the
coronavirus
which probably may have been
caused by science and that's when he
goes into the joke and he compares
the the lab and wuhan with a hershey's
chocolate factory lab
that that was the joke and it is funny
it is [ __ ] funny it doesn't matter
what the truth is because the truth that
he was trying to say
was that the lab name is the same his
name is the the coronavirus
they're the same name that's the truth
he doesn't know if it's from the lab
what the [ __ ] does jon stewart know if
it's from the lab four
he doesn't know more than me or you or
anyone else
he has no clue it appears that way and
it's especially funny when you look at
it through the lens
of the name of the lab is the name of
the virus
that's all he was doing was pointing at
the hilarity of it
it's comedy it's comedy folks it's
it's supposed to be funny
it's not supposed to be news
and it's not supposed to be some
conspiracy theory because jon stewart
said it on the light show
with stephen colbert you people hate
[ __ ] stephen colbert
number one why would you believe
anything that was on his goddamn
show
and yet jon stewart says it on the show
must be true because i believe it
it's a joke you dumb [ __ ] it's
a joke
and jokes are exaggerations of the truth
and the exaggeration that he was making
was to the name of the lab in the name
of the virus
that was it but you [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] ran straight into the point
of his joke
straight into it and you couldn't even
[ __ ] see it in the beginning
when he talks about how science saved us
in other words in other words you
[ __ ] boneheads believe this
what may or may not be true about a
wuhan lab but you won't believe anything
else any other proof any other [ __ ]
facts you don't give a [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ] if to believe that
garbage
but one thing is true one thing's true
one goddamn thing's true and all the
rest of the stuff that i say that's
[ __ ] is true but you won't believe
anything else anyone else is telling you
you [ __ ] ran around for a year and a
half talking about how
how masks make you sick
you dumb [ __ ]
as if as if the masks make you sick
or don't make you sick or don't spread
the virus see the way you look at it
is is any any less of a point a to point
b
stretch than the name of the lab and the
name of the virus
and where it came from
get your [ __ ] heads out of your asses
enough of this head-up ass syndrome
again the joke was made by jon stewart
and the
exaggeration and the hilarious part
about the
if it is leaked and wuhan in that lab if
that is the truth i
who i will find out eventually
china's trying to block it so that would
give indication that that's possibly
true
but it could be a wild goose chase as
well with them who the [ __ ] knows
but now that we have a decent [ __ ]
administration in charge
we'll probably get to the bottom of it
now that
now that democrats run the congress
we'll probably get to the bottom of it
with the last administration and the
last [ __ ] senate we had they don't
wouldn't give a [ __ ] to work
the [ __ ] you don't get up and work
during the day you get up and produce a
route reality tv show
trumpster fire tv showism
but now that we actually have a
government in place diplomats in place
experts in place we they may get to the
bottom of it they may find out exactly
where that [ __ ] came from and
how it came and where it came and all
the facts
and lay it out for us
[Music]
and until then i think jon stewart
should keep making [ __ ] jokes about
it because it points out how stupid you
dumb [ __ ] are
about you believe one thing one thing
that jon stewart says because he said
what you believe or you think he said
what you believe
he was really making fun of how stupid
it is
but you don't [ __ ] see it you don't
get it because you don't get funny you
don't get comedy
you can go over to fox news and watch
these chuckleheads try to tell jokes
and you can tell they don't understand
how [ __ ] comedy works
all right enough of that [ __ ] so let's
let's get to
uh the the helsiki meeting today
with president your president
our president the president of the
united states
joseph biden
and vlady daddy vlady putin the
republicans
the republicans love vladimir putin
they love him and the reason why they
love him is because he spews out their
anti-democratic fascist [ __ ]
and it was really if you listen to any
part of the
vladimir putin a press conference
afterwards where he
[ __ ] puked into the microphone he
puked trumpisms into the microphone
and this is where trump got the [ __ ]
this is where vladimir putin got the
[ __ ] that's why i tweeted
that joe biden made vladimir putin
switch to the trump brand diapers
because he he's he's already
regurgitating
the the the wedding crap the mar-a-lago
wedding crashers act
he's stolen it stolen his [ __ ] act
trump should really really should sue
vladimir putin
for stealing his material here i mean
it's a serious violation
i mean he's stealing copyrighted
[ __ ] is what he's doing
trump should really make sure that he
sues vladimir putin for stealing his
material his stand-up material
that he crashes weddings and funerals at
mar-a-lago with i mean how else is he
gonna have
of living after he gets criminally
indicted and criminally prosecuted in
the federal and the state
courts how else is he gonna make a
living besides
you know doing open mics at weddings and
funerals at mar-a-lago
how else is he gonna survive
i don't know he needs to sue putin for
stealing his material that's what i
believe
and it's a serious [ __ ] violation of
theft
of copyrighted [ __ ]
but it seems as if uh after after the
meeting they had a uh the secretary of
state
lincoln and uh president biden met with
putin
putin daddy vlady as the republicans
might call him
daddy blatty i saw someone was saying
poo pooty
oh [ __ ] the nicknames the nicknames
and they met they met privately and then
uh for an hour and a half and then they
met for
an hour or so afterwards with the whole
group of people um
to to let bite or to for biden to let
putin know that yes
yes trump is not the president anymore
and trump does not have his tentacles
inside the state department
so watch your [ __ ] [ __ ] uh
it's it this is abby putin knows this
this is why putin wanted to sow chaos in
2016 that's why he actively tried to get
trump elected
and once he got trump elected he was
pleasantly surprised that
uh trump put on his putin knee pads
and serviced service the putin poll
like back in 2018 when he met privately
and then they had a joint
conference and he basically swooned over
putin
because trump that's that's the thing is
trump would have loved to be putin in
this country
loved it uh where he could kill his
political enemies poison them
jail people you know uh
lock up the opposition party i mean you
know he would love to do that and that
was his [ __ ] fantasy
and putin's doing that now and he was
questioned about that at his press
conference
and of course he gave trumpy and type
ampere answers which they might be putin
type answer that's the way trump
answered who knows who knows hands up
whose ass and who the puppet is
who the [ __ ] can tell anymore
i mean that the great news about what
happened with uh
biden today is uh america's back
america's diplomacy is back the state
department's back
putin knows it and basically joe biden
and the the american diplomatic arm is
made putin more irrelevant than donald
trump
so now vladimir putin can go back to the
kremlin
and the the russian mar-a-lago
and maybe he can do open mics at
weddings and funerals there
because he's about he's just about as
irrelevant
as donald trump and really honestly uh i
believe this is the beginning of the end
of vladimir putin
if the warning is true if the warning is
true that the president warned
putin that alexi navali
better not die in prison there will be
consequences if your political opponent
dies in prison
i think it probably was a clear sign of
we're watching you [ __ ]
so i i believe that uh uh
this is probably the slow walk um
away from putin and the right wing in
this world uh we watched as
bb netanyahu hang on by his fingernails
in israel uh and he he yelled and
screamed that oh my god if i'm gone the
right wing is gone in this world which
we could do without a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] poop nazis for sure
uh and we're gonna talk about
nickaboot nazis later in marjory taylor
green and she loves putin
she loves putin loves him loves him oh
loves
why i'm on that subject i might as well
play my world famous putin's puppies
because this really this video here if
you want to really
get underneath these [ __ ] skin
uh really send out this
this video it's it's called putin's
puppies
it's it's on tick tock it's on twitter
it's it's it's there
and now it's gonna be on youtube here
and it may be on youtube already i'm not
i'm not real sure i might have posted it
on youtube
as an individual video but uh it talks
about
how and this was a couple months ago
where
fox news was just uh all in 110
with putin putin's the strongest guy
ever and because he's strong
uh uh biden's weak i mean this is when
trump was really irrelevant
i mean before he started his blog and
that failed
um they really needed a new leader they
needed someone they needed
a strong man they needed somebody to
turn to
that they could get some content from so
they were turning and trying to
get vladimir putin uh daddy vlady
as i refer to him and uh so i did a
little video a little
walking [ __ ] rant and and tried to
surmise
who would replace the
recently stomped
donald trump so let's listen to that and
i'll talk about it putin's
puppies let's talk ever since donald
trump got [ __ ]
crushed in the last election the
republicans and fox news have been
trying to find themselves
a relevant leader slim ball dead tucker
carlson yeah no one's going to vote for
that [ __ ] back hush holly yeah he might
do some time in the clan
sugar junior yeah well the campaign
funds might all go up his nose
space laser lunatic nah ted cruz ah he
was born in another country hey
speaking of people in other countries
see who do we have
hmm it really needs to be an
authoritarian murderous dictator you
know someone that can
kill his political opponents that's the
only way they're gonna [ __ ] win
foreign country murderous dictator huh
oh [ __ ] putin of course you insecure
makismo boneheaded [ __ ]
think that vladimir putin is some kind
of tough guy
you dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] them
and it's it's it's completely true that
these
these trump flag waving morons
think that vladimir putin is some kind
of tough guy it's the same guy that
walks into a subway
shop with a with a bazooka on his back
to order a subway sandwich because he
thinks
it makes him tough and the same guy that
thinks vladimir putin is tough because
he
his four foot ass rides shirtless on a
horse and takes pictures and
puffs his chest out thinks they're tough
that's the opposite of mckees mode
actually
but you know whatever we'll move on from
that so
vladimir putin uh during his little
his little q a with the press uh he
they asked him several different things
number one the the question that i
thought was one of the most significant
questions
that made it very evident that vladimir
putin
was was really and i thought
had his pants pulled down and spanked
with a belt today
was the one of the very last questions
when they asked him about
young protesters uh why he thought
it was okay to jail and keep
people young people from protesting
and he rambles it really sounds i mean
if you go back and listen to it the
translation it sounds so much like a
[ __ ] trump answer
just rambling on and on and on about all
kinds of [ __ ]
not answering the question at all about
protesters he didn't even say the
[ __ ] word protest i mean
he didn't even get to the crux of what
the question was he just rambles on and
on and on
and hopefully that that they'll stop the
press conference i guess
so that that that that last question
there told me
that vladimir putin really uh not was
shaken today because vladimir putin
knows exactly what what is happening
here
he's not a [ __ ] dummy he he knows
he knows that his interests are not
great
when the american democracy is strong he
knows that that's why he wants to weaken
us
that's why he wanted to get involved in
2016 that's why he [ __ ] around in 2018
and he wanted to continue to have the
the [ __ ] baby in chief
as our president because it sews chaos
and it destroys our democracy inch by
inch by inch
i mean jesus christ he's convinced all
these republicans that we're not even a
democracy
it's not a democracy it's okay to
overtake the government of the united
states as long as it's in the name of
trump
that's where we're at
so he also is asked a question
about murdering people and murdering his
political opponents and jailing his
political opponents
jailing the opposition banning the
opposition from protesting
uh and and he compares putin can he
starts to talk about the january 6
insurrection he gets it all confused
about what's it about and how it works
uh he says basically he's trying to
prevent a january six
insurrection in his country which by
that logic
would mean would mean that the january
six
insurrection was was trying to overturn
the government of the united states
which it was
so putin's saying hey those trump
supporters boy they're really
they're really [ __ ] around they're
gonna overturn the government
yeah no [ __ ] and then he's then he does
the stupid republican stupid thing
where he he he [ __ ] conflates this
thing with black lives matter and
because they asked him about black lives
matter and he said the black lives
matter was a bad thing
the same [ __ ] reason same [ __ ]
[ __ ] reason of course
of course vladimir putin doesn't want
black lives
matter to take hold in russia he doesn't
want any kind of
movement in russia to take hold because
any kind of movement in russia that
would empower people
would empower people against him that's
the whole [ __ ] point that's why
republicans didn't like the black lives
matter rallies last year
that's why they keep conflating it with
the january six insurrection they keep
jesus christ they were questioning the
director of the fbi yesterday
christopher wray
and they couldn't help they couldn't
help but talk about the black lives
matter
movement last year and how they protest
the death of george floyd
and somehow that has to do with the
insurrection
because you know and then we're going to
talk about this here in a second with
marjorie taylor green because she does
the same stupid nicka poop nazi thing
too these [ __ ] fascists
but the best part the best part about
the press conference
and what everyone should remember about
the press conference the meeting the
whole goddamn thing
the whole god damn thing the most
important thing that you need to
remember here
is that when president
biden was speaking and answering
questions he
referred to putin as president trump or
trump as putin you know
who the [ __ ] is counting and that's the
most important thing here
is the freudian slip is always probably
the truth
and the truth is is that trump's not far
away from putin and putin's not far away
from trump
who's got whose hand up whose ass who
knows it's likely putin's got his hand
up trump's ass
and we're going to find out about that
in these criminal investigations
and these congressional and civil
investigations
that's why they don't want a january 6
[ __ ] investigation
because they know this is all going to
lead back to
[ __ ] russian influence and russian
money somewhere
and these republicans don't don't want
people to know what we already know they
love them some putin i mean jesus christ
they hold it out there for everyone to
see
so that's the one thing i want you to
take away
the one thing i want you to take away
from the the biden versus putin match
is that is that vladimir putin is donald
trump donald trump is vladimir putin
and joe biden made daddy vlady uh switch
to the trump brand diapers
because the rhetoric from vladimir putin
out of the kremlin the mar-a-lago of
russia
sounds like the disgraced two-time
impeached
wedding crasher down at mar-a-lago they
they mirror each other
the same [ __ ] machine the same lines
the same material and
by god donald trump if you're listening
you need to sue
your pimp daddy vladimir daddy vlady
putin
if you're listening you need to sue and
be stealing your [ __ ] material
so we'll move on from that the uh the
biden first putin match because
honestly i don't i don't think it
changes much everyone's oh you shouldn't
have met with him and he should have met
with him and he shouldn't have met with
him
look the only way for bro biden to let
putin know
don't [ __ ] around is to look him in the
eyes and tell him don't [ __ ] around
okay that's what obama did with him
don't [ __ ]
around the last guy wanted him to [ __ ]
around the republicans
the fascists in this country want
vladimir putin to [ __ ] around
the only way they're gonna win is to
cheat and vladimir putin
may just give them the edge
that's what they that's why why they
don't give a [ __ ] that russian
influence had anything to do with 2016
2018 midterms in the 2020 election
is because vladimir putin and the
russians give them the edge
to win and anything to win because [ __ ]
democracy [ __ ] majority [ __ ] what the
people want
they don't give a [ __ ] it ain't even
about money anymore it's about
power because they're about to [ __ ]
lose it
because i think the backlash of all
these laws that they're trying to pass
in these states
is gonna kick their ass that's why i
think this is the beginning of the end
of vladimir putin just like it was the
beginning of the end of bibi netanyahu
in israel and trump lost
there's not much hanging on there so
let's thank our lucky stars that we got
a president who knows
just a little bit more than nothing
about foreign policy at this point
that's the best situation that we could
be in
is that he knows more than nothing which
the last guy not
knowing not a [ __ ] thing about
foreign policy
so let's just call it good
so let's move on to the marjorie taylor
green you remember
several weeks ago this stupid [ __ ] idiot
compared wearing mass to the holocaust
which
i'm not even going to get into i'm not
even going to get into the comparison
i could go on and on and on for two
hours about the comparison of the mask
and the holocaust
and it'd only get me in trouble with
time wise here on the podcast
because i i want to get to the fact that
this [ __ ] didn't know what the [ __ ] the
holocaust was
so she makes a comparison of of people
being forced to wear mask
uh to the holocaust which again
no one is being forced to do anything
you don't have to go in a place that
requires you to wear a mask you don't
have to
it's it's not a thing you have to do
just don't you haven't for a year and a
half and really frankly in most the
areas
where most these [ __ ] q anon maga
anti-backs anti-masters live
they they weren't wearing masks in the
first place i live in one and
a lot of them weren't wearing [ __ ]
masks because they don't have
[ __ ] manners and neither does
marjorie taylor green
comparing mass to the holocaust and and
we find out that not only didn't she
have manners
she didn't know what the [ __ ]
holocaust was well at least that's what
she tried to make it look like
which i don't think that's actually the
[ __ ] case i i don't i don't [ __ ]
believe for a second
that she [ __ ] didn't know what the
holocaust was and she had to go to a
goddamn holocaust
museum to figure out what the [ __ ] the
holocaust was
does anyone believe that [ __ ] garbage
that a 47 year old person
doesn't know what the [ __ ] happened
during the holocaust and how it
shouldn't compare to
people wearing masks during a a
pandemic where a deadly pathogen
was killing people
i mean a 47 year old woman can't figure
that out
she has to go to a holocaust museum to
figure that out
so i don't believe that garbage i think
this is all [ __ ] stunt and the reason
why i think it was a [ __ ] stunt
and i'll tell you the reason why i think
she did it but the reason why i think
it's a [ __ ] stunt
is because she was on bannon's war room
the very next [ __ ] day
yelling and screaming or nazi propaganda
about january 6 the fbi and there it's
not an insurrection
and getting all turned around all
confused these people don't know what
they [ __ ] believe anymore
they have no [ __ ] clue not a goddamn
clue
but the reason why marjorie taylor green
went to the holocaust museum
and then proceeded to walk out in front
of a microphone and
the first thing she says is i'm a normal
person
i'm a normal per yeah okay well when you
have to
walk out in front of a microphone and
tell the world
and reassure them that you're a normal
person
that only that only makes me believe
that you believe that the majority of
people don't think you're [ __ ] normal
they think you're off your [ __ ]
rocker
because you are you're in the deep end
lady
you have no idea what the [ __ ] you're
talking about you [ __ ]
fascist
i'm a normal person i'm not a racist
but same [ __ ] [ __ ]
same [ __ ] [ __ ] when you hear someone
say i'm not a racist
but you know all that shit's gonna be
racist after the butt
i'm a normal person but all that shit's
gonna be [ __ ] nonsense just [ __ ]
utter nonsense
i'm a normal person but
i didn't know what the holocaust was i'm
real sorry that i said those things
that offended all the corporate money
and they're not giving us
corporate dollars and no one's donating
anywhere to anybody anymore because of
my craziness
so i'm gonna stand in front of the
microphone and apologize for something
i'm not sorry for
because i'm a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
holocaust or the mask or any
[ __ ] she's the reason why she stood
out front of a microphone is because
they can't
corporations and banks and all these
people they can't be giving money
to people who don't know what the [ __ ]
the holocaust is
and spewing [ __ ] into a microphone about
how the holocaust compares to this or
the holocaust compares to that or this
or that or whatever the [ __ ] they want
to
say come on that's why
the money's drying up the money's drying
up
well why do you think they're so [ __ ]
desperate to change voting laws
they know they're gonna have to change
those [ __ ] access to ballots
by god we're gonna have to change it and
if
and if and if they do vote they're even
changing laws if we do vote for the
democrat
the republican legislators in those
states can just say
nope we don't agree with you we're just
gonna
we're just gonna get rid of the the the
election the hell with it
we'll just get rid of it we won't have
that thing that you just did
like they did here in missouri with
medicaid expansion we passed the people
in the missouri did a mandate they
passed medicaid expansion in the state
of missouri
and the republican legislators said you
don't know what the [ __ ] you want you
don't know what you're doing
[ __ ] you
and that's the laws that they're trying
to write
so get out there and [ __ ] vote it's
time we bury these fascists in a
mountain of votes
like marjorie taylor green who goes on
bannon's war room
and gets all confused about the january
6th insurrection
so let's break this down and let's start
from the [ __ ] beginning here let's
start for
with january 6th um i can't even believe
we have to [ __ ]
do a timeline here to figure out what
the [ __ ] these people believe and what
they don't believe because they believe
a hundred different things apparently
so on january 6 donald trump incites his
his rally his peaceful rally
and they go and storm the capitol that
day
he does several videos
and says we love you thank you they were
his supporters then
hours later they were criminals and then
a couple days later it was black lives
matter and antifa
then ron johnson seen a nazi propaganda
blog and was sure it was antifa
no way that it's trump supporters it was
all antifa
then they had to pull back on that
because all these people that were being
arrested like we're not antifa
we're trump supporters
and then they're like oh you're going to
federally prosecute us
well [ __ ] we're not trump supporters he
duped us but we are trump supporters but
we're not
but he duped us he duked us into
believing [ __ ] that wasn't real but i
still support him and i think he's gonna
be president in august
we go through that stage of the movement
then we get up to ashley babbitt
where the spouse of ashley babbitt her
husband
wants the name of the police officer you
know so they can dox him out
him threaten him yeah that's what they
want to do they want to tear him through
the
through the mud here because donald
trump duke turd convinced her of lies to
go into the capitol and
try to commit a coup for him and she was
shot and killed because
she went past a secure area where they
have to use deadly force
to prevent anyone from harming the
speaker or lawmakers in that secure area
that is what happened if you got near
the president donald trump
barack obama biden clinton bush it
didn't matter
they'd use the same type of deadly force
possibly if they had to
that's that's what they would do that
that's what they would do
they would use deadly force and of
course
no one sees it through the actual lens
that donald trump
and by no one i mean no one on the right
actually sees it through the lens of
the ashrae babbitt she died because she
believed donald trump's lies
and he stoked this lie to get these
morons to go into the capital and do
what they did and it got her killed
it got her killed it got several people
killed that day and she's one of them
she was a cheeto dust sacrifice as i put
it in my video
to have you ever noticed cheeto dust
sacrifice is what she is what she was
what she'll always be she's no [ __ ]
hero
she didn't kill herself she's a cheeto
dust sacrifice donald trump's lies
killed her
and her delusion of those lies got her
killed
and he stoked that delusion and
continued that day
then then
we have testimony from the fbi
about january 6th and all of a sudden
all of a sudden marjorie taylor green
goes on steve bannon's war room
yesterday and surmises that
maybe it was the fbi that did this you
know
we couldn't we couldn't figure out how
to frame it up
that the trump supporters were a good it
was a good thing that they did
so we shouldn't call it an insurrection
it wasn't a riot it was a protest and
they were tourists they were touring the
capital god damn it but maybe they
weren't actually touring the capital
maybe they were
that maybe it was the fbi that actually
how the
where and then tucker carlson repeats
this [ __ ] on air last night
and tucker carlson uh doesn't even
understand he he tries to connect um
redacted co-conspirators in these
conspiracy indictments
uh as fbi informants but
clearly right there he doesn't know how
fbi informants work
fbi informants do not appear as indicted
co-conspirators
on a conspiracy indictment they don't
that's not how it works it's actually
against the [ __ ] law
but you know whatever it would be tough
to
have a legal expert on your team to look
that up probably
when you're you know on a place like fox
news
you dumb other [ __ ]
but tucker carlson spews this [ __ ] last
night and the thing
the thing that i i love about the little
clip of him trying to convince
his viewers that it's the fbi because he
knows it's all horse [ __ ]
he knows it they know it that he's
trying to
and he's trying to coax his viewers into
blaming
the next scapegoat you know they're
always moving the goal post here
i mean you know donald trump when it
comes to august it'll be december it'll
be next year dude
who the [ __ ] knows they've already got a
theory that they're gonna win back the
house and he's gonna be the speaker of
the house and he's gonna ascend to the
presidency
because the order of the 25th amendment
or some [ __ ] i don't know
they're [ __ ] out of their goddamn
minds
out of their minds they they they didn't
listen for months and months and months
what we were saying
about if if joe biden wasn't
wasn't elected that nancy pelosi would
be the [ __ ] president and then they
finally listened and now that's their
plan that's their plan
now is to make him president is to get
him to be speakers somehow
jesus [ __ ] christ he's [ __ ] people
but back to tucker carlson this [ __ ]
idiot
is trying to he's trying to convince his
audience that hey
it's not antifa we thought it was
it's not it's not hunter biden's laptop
it's probably not that that probably
didn't cause the january 6 instruction
even though that would be really cool
if we could get hunter biden's laptop to
really cause the january 6 insurrection
it wasn't hillary clinton that was
benghazi
it it we can't we can't call it an
insurrection because trump supporters
actually were there and they've been
arrested there's over 500 of them now
that have been arrested and charged so
we can't really call it an insurrection
because we don't want to offend those
people
so maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe just maybe
it was the fbi somehow
the fbi is responsible because you know
the fbi could be an enemy here and the
reason why the fbi could be an enemy is
because apparently
the fbi was was receiving information
about january 6 and they did nothing
about it
nothing how the [ __ ] i mean if the fbi
had anything to do with the january 6 in
direction it ain't because they
they were [ __ ] there they were the
ones who organized it
they ignored the [ __ ] signs that it
was coming
if anything so yeah maybe the fbi is
responsible they just weren't there
going into the capitol [ __ ] boneheads
but here we are they can't even figure
out what they believe
they can't they can't they can't figure
it out they just
they just can't they can't
they don't know how to put two thoughts
together
speaking of the january 6 insurrection
it looks like and we have the vladimir
putin in the news today
uh let's get to these trump
investigations again i i could
i could do a show for 12 hours and not
get to every single detail on these
trump investigations
uh there's there's there's 30 in total
is what we can count
uh thank you bad company for sending me
some information on
these uh 30 total
there's 12 apparently 12 congressional
investigations 10 federal criminal
investigations and eight state and local
investigations
now the most important congressional
investigation
i believe into donald trump is going to
be
this january 6 insurrection because not
only is it important about donald trump
but it is also important about other
lawmakers that currently hold office
uh and i believe that's why we need to
keep yelling and screaming yelling and
screaming about january 6
getting some sort of quote-unquote a
commission whatever the [ __ ] that looks
like
rather it's a a special goddamn
council uh we we can get a benghazi
get some benghazi style hearings or
actually get these dumb [ __ ]
to get a 911 style commission either way
whatever the [ __ ] you got to do
let's do that congressionally because
we're going to work we're going to see
this january 6 stuff play out
inside court inside federal court as
these people are being prosecuted
because there's a lot of these people
that are
up against 20 25 years and a lot of them
are not going to plead guilty they're
going to go
to to to trial which is going to
basically have it all out there
put two and two and two and together so
the congressional investigation i
believe the most important ones at this
point
um the trump that have anything to do
with trump trump associates trump allies
uh trump cronies this corruption this
trump corruption that happened
because we have to we have to we have to
figure that out
that when we're talking about trump and
we're trying to [ __ ] sniff out all
this [ __ ] with trump it's not just
him
it's not just that [ __ ] it's all
the corruption and all the [ __ ] that
he caused
to undermine our democracy and to
continue to undermine our democracy
that's what we need to know that's what
we need to do that's what we need to
focus on
so when you say trump or trump
administration or whatever
you don't just mean that fat [ __ ]
slob down in mar-a-lago crashing
weddings
or funerals i heard he's crashing
funerals now you know he's trying his
material out on different audiences
but we're talking about that we're
talking about
all of them the trump
trumpster reality tv
show showism that's what trumpism that's
what we're talking about
and we need to continue to pound that
sand and beat it with a sledgehammer
keep going after it and after it and
after it and after it
to sniff out why and how they [ __ ]
tried to tear down our democracy and are
continuing to do that
that's the only way to [ __ ] save it
really that's the only way
now i don't believe donald trump's a
threat
but i believe the thought
that that he has towards democracy and
how democracy doesn't work like vladimir
putin and these [ __ ] analyze vladimir
putin that's the threat
so the most important congressional
investigation that we can have is to
sniff out these [ __ ] that are
still inside of our government
these elected officials that had
anything to do with that criminally
or ethically and sniff those
[ __ ] out
whoever they are and we can run down a
whole goddamn list right here right now
but i ain't got time there's too [ __ ]
many of them in congress
that probably had something to do with
it
and there's already evidence and and
tucker carlson you dumb [ __ ]
the person that's redacted and that
conspiracy
indictment it's probably someone of
importance
like a member of congress or the senate
you dumb [ __ ]
or maybe a former official of some kind
of an administration
you know that we won't talk about
now let's get on to the federal criminal
investigations
because there's there's 10 federal
criminal investigations either into
trump
or connected to trump somehow the one
that i think is one of the most
significant
most significant investigations is what
has to do with rudy giuliani
that is the one one of the most
significant
as far as sniffing out who else who
else is installed or who else is
anywhere near anything to do with our
democracy
and had anything to do with
the ukraine deal the the the [ __ ]
rudy giuliani
i'll give you this you give me that quid
pro quo [ __ ]
we'll give you aid if if you give us an
investigation
that's what it was that's nice federal
aid you got there it would be a shame to
something
happened to it it's what it was that's
what the phone call was
where he's eating his bologna sandwich
that fat slob that's what it was
so that's probably one of the most
important and that's probably one of the
first ones that we're going to see
but there's several other federal
investigations into
uh these dumb these dumb [ __ ] not
not uh excluding even the insurrection
there's
hundreds hundreds and hundreds of
investigations that are going to lead
back to trump
and his allies and his cronies and this
corruption through
uh the january 6th i mean christopher
wray yesterday they've already got 500
they plan on having
it sounds like seven or six to 700
indictments
a people indicted having to do it
january
6th that they're still looking for over
a hundred of those people to charge them
so my guess is we're going to have up to
700
people being indicted one way or another
for january 6
and there's gonna be handfuls of them
that are gonna get conspiracy charges
which are gonna be the
the hardest charges to get away from and
they're gonna carry the biggest
sentences
and it's gonna rope so many other people
into that conspiracy and that's how
they're going to get them to plea
and rat and tell the truth and that's
how it works that's how the feds work
they use leverage of time money
and your ass now
there's also eight state and local
investigations
um the the most important one obviously
is the one in the manhattan da's office
uh i believe uh weisselberg
which maybe we should refer to him as
weissel [ __ ]
um here and
the weisselberg
appears apparently appears that
he is going to be charged during the
summer by the state of new york
uh my guess is is there's probably
already a sealed indictment
on weisselberg and weisselberg has
already started to flip
um that that's that's they're trying to
to try to scare the bejesus out of the
other people in the trump administration
the trump organization jesus christ
now the trump organization uh not just
trump himself but also
uh uh the the the children and other
people that
weisselberg himself but i i believe uh
that
that they are a hell of a lot closer
than anyone can ever imagine
uh to criminal charges to those people
and so to
to leak out that weisselberg is going to
be charged this summer
would give weisselberg some cover uh
when these people are trying to pressure
him because i believe that's what
they're doing they're just trying to see
what these [ __ ] are going to do
what they're capable of now what kind of
intimidation tactics
they're going to use i mean jesus christ
michael cohen today this was news
this is why don jr and ivanka are
trending on twitter
is because cohen basically says that
trump has said
i would rather don junior go to prison
than ivanka
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course he would of course he would
and in other words
it sounds like trump's role in the day
so who's going to go to prison for him
at this point
whether it's weisselberg don jr ivanka
i i i don't i don't i mean we'd love to
see
eric get getting uh uh orange jumpsuit
but who knows if he's smart enough to
even know
anything about this to to be criminal
activity
at [ __ ] bonehead but
that i think is the most important state
and local uh
investigation we also have
investigations out of georgia
that apparently looks like uh the reason
why
brad rathersberger and that could turn
into a federal investigation as well
uh brad ratlisberger recorded the phone
call with donald trump
and the reason why we know this is
because of emails that were leaked
about mark meadows and sending a [ __ ]
youtube video
uh to rosen the acting attorney general
derozan
and this guy's like what the [ __ ] are
you sending me a youtube video for what
the hell is this and
and and then uh clark he was he's a
crazier more batshit crazy
uh he was the acting deputy attorney
general
at the time and apparently uh rosen
wouldn't play ball with trump to install
him as president as if the
attorney general has the power to wave a
magic wand and make someone president
this is all delusion the same [ __ ]
delusion that they had about mike pence
during the certification on january 6
how he had the power just to
dean trump the [ __ ] king or some [ __ ]
that's not how it works and the attorney
general does not have the power to
overturn the election or
tell the supreme court to overturn state
certifications
that's why bill barr [ __ ] resigned in
december is because bill barr
walked right up to the i'm going to
commit crime or i'm not going to commit
crimeline
and walked away he know and bill bart's
not [ __ ] dumb he knew what was a
crime and what wasn't
i mean jesus christ they're even going
to try to pin him up with perjury but
the way he
he danced around the word suggest in his
congressional testimony
he didn't perjure himself unfortunately
now let's hope he committed crimes but
who knows bill barr is not that dumb
that's why he resigned in december
before he
planned on resigning is because he knew
trump wanted him to commit crimes
and he continued to pressure rosin to
commit crimes and he thought oh well
clark will commit crimes for me so let's
get that guy to be the attorney general
so that was a good [ __ ] idea let's do
that
and that's how we know that's how we
know now that phone call that was made
to
the secretary of state in georgia brad
rathersberger
why he recorded it he recorded the phone
call folks
he recorded the phone call because he
knew trump was going to call
and ask him to commit a crime
he knew that's what was going to happen
he knew
donald trump the president at the time
is going to call him and ask him to
commit
a crime and rather burger knew that if
he didn't record it and have the
evidence
that everyone on the phone call that
wasn't him and his people
would say that's not what was said that
he didn't say that we got that read the
transcript you remember this
read it's a perfect phone call perfect
it was perfect you remember this script
it was perfect oh read the transcript
a perfect call perfect no collusion
no obstruction yeah well it was it was
someone trying to convince a secretary
of state and their party to commit voter
fraud
just fine just find me the amount of
votes that i need
just find them wherever you got to find
them in your desk drawer wherever
and let's do that and make me king
rattus burger knew that rather burger
knew trump was gonna call
and ask him to commit a crime which is a
crime
that's why he recorded it and then when
when he didn't do
when rather burger didn't do what trump
did and trump attacked him on twitter
rather burger released the tape ahead of
time rather burger was just gonna hold
this receipt
he just took his receipt to make sure he
could get out the door
folks but trump challenged him before it
before it was over
raptors burger probably was holding on
to this tape hoping never to have to
reveal it
but trump forced him to because trump
did exactly what rather burger thought
he was going to do
cause trump is predictably unpredictable
he's not a [ __ ] mystery trump is not
a mystery
he's not why is anyone surprised that
this fat
old slob is down at mar-a-lago
practicing his open mic
speech at funerals and weddings
you shouldn't be surprised there's no
surprise
he's a [ __ ] bag pretty [ __ ] simple
so i believe that's probably the most
important uh
other than the manhattan d.a case the
most important uh case when it comes to
trump and his allies
uh of pressuring state officials on the
election
uh trying to get them to to commit uh
fraud trying to get them to commit crime
for him to remain
president and uh you know that's that's
why a lot of this stuff is going to get
away folks
a lot of this stuff on trump and his
allies is going to get away it's going
to get loose
and the reason why it's going to get
loose is because there's so many more
investigations there's so many [ __ ]
rocks to unturn with these stupid
bastards
because they continued to attack our
democracy and the way that they attacked
it is they held trump up they held that
fascist up and high
and they continued to do it even putin
was emulating him today
on how to kill american democracy that's
what putin was trying to do
today was kill and hurt american
democracy
well guess what [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you ain't gonna do it
it ain't gonna happen not here not there
not ever
go bury these fascist [ __ ] and votes
people
vote vote vote vote vote
vote a matters dog catcher if you have
to [ __ ] them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em